[Music]  Beyonce teaches us how lemonade is made  last april queen bee literally stunned  the world with the gorgeous visuals for  her sixth studio album and its many  implied revelations about her marriage  to jay-z now she's releasing an over 600  page hardcover book called how to make  lemonade and it is everything I wanted  it to be something iconic and something  that people will never forget taking an  in-depth look at each element of  lemonade's visual presentation these  book highlights the inspiration behind  some of the film's most provocative  moments catch my face and features these  never before seen photos which are pure  gold we can always count on Queen B to  deliver but it'll cost you the entire  package retails for $300  [Music]  you